l'inquiétude pour paul vanden boeynants
où a disparu l'ancien premier ministre
belge
la réponse est peut-être dans sa propre
vie l'opéra dans tous ses états personne
ne veut céder à propos de la bastille
c'est le président de la république qui
devrait trancher
les affaires se transforme en violente
polémique
edouard balladur l'ancien ministre de
l'économie contre attaque sur le thème
des noyaux durs l'enseignement examiné à
la loupe
à partir de demain lionel jospin le
ministre reçoive tous les partenaires
les uns après les autres
avoriaz sous le signe des petites bêtes
au festival du film fantastique
l'animal est roi une fois encore bonsoir
et tout d'abord la sphère vanden borre
heinze cet après-midi les battues ont
été interrompues vers 19h mais toutes
les polices de belgique continuent de
rechercher l'ancien premier ministre
belge monsieur vanden bemden ça a
disparu samedi soir devant son domicile
dans les heures qui ont suivi deux
organisations inconnus ont revendiqué un
hypothétique enlèvement il avait levé
clair notre envoyé spécial est à
bruxelles d'enquêteurs qui travaille
depuis hier matin à élucider la
disparition de l'ancien premier ministre
belge
aucune hypothèse n'est à écarter en
effet personne ici ne connaît les
brigades socialistes révolutionnaires
qui ont revendiqué l'enlèvement avant
que l'information de son public
n'importe qui pourra se cacher derrière
cette appellation pas seulement un
groupe politique ou terroristes mais
aussi par exemple un rival en affaires
ou bien des malfaiteurs aux attentions
crapuleuses ce que l'on sait c'est que
l'ancien premier ministre avait reçu des
menaces ces derniers temps et qu'il
devait rencontrer aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur
d'un côté j'étais assez surpris qu'ils
me demandent gardez vous de notre côté
je dis que il a dû estimer lui-même
qu'il n'y avait pas le feu
parce que si entre le jeudi il est le
lundi il avait laissé quatre jours c'est
que ce n'est pas parce que moi je
n'avais pas voulu je n'aurais pas voulu
de recevoir plutôt donc ce qu'il a dû
considérer qu avant que ce n'était pas
si urgent que cela c'était un homme
d'envergure que vous respectiez malgré
les accidents à qui la justice qu'il est
vous savez il aléas de ce qui est humain
ne lui était
lui était étranger cet après midi sur la
foi d'un coup de téléphone anonyme
l'armée a fouillé les 17 hectares du
bois de baudour près de mons sans succès
oui et ce qui rend la faire plus
compliqué c'est que la vie de monsieur
vanden boeynants ça a été bien agitée
son nom a été mêlé à plusieurs scandales
politico financiers
il avait été accusé par exemple de
fraude fiscale et à cause de cela
il avait même dû renoncer à la mairie de
bruxelles très récemment hervé brusini a
retracé les étapes de cette vie
politique mouvementée j'ai informé le
premier ministre de ma décision de ne
pas soumettre à sa majesté le roi ma
candidature au poste de bourgmestre à
bruxelles car le scandale avait été le
plus fort paul van dyk bones homme
politique très populaire là bas on
l'appelle vdb se retrouvaient impliqué
dans une affaire de pots de vin deux ans
auparavant déjà la justice l'avait
condamné à une forte amende et trois ans
de prison avec sursis
cette fois il s'agissait de sociétés
fictives il y a des centaines de preuve
dans le dossier avait dit le président
du tribunal bruxellois pour ajouté vous
êtes un fraudeur fiscal viscérale et
invétéré mais vanden boeynants ce ne
devait pas se laisser abattre deux fois
premier ministre cinq fois membre du
gouvernement
ce social chrétien reparti à la source
de la mairie de bruxelles le tollé
l'indignation générale ne l'ont pourtant
pas permis d'aller au bout de cette
ambition celui que l'on surnomme le
crocodile a donc une carrière politique
des plus mouvementées une carrière qu'il
n'ignorait pas tant s'en faut le monde
du business
cela aussi fait partie des pistes
actuellement explorées par les
enquêteurs
le feuilleton de l'opéra-bastille tourne
à la cacophonie aujourd'hui tous les
protagonistes en appelle au président de
la république
alors d'un côté il y à bahreïn comme le
chef d'orchestre prestigieux qui vient
d'être remercié il dit que les artistes
sont solidaires avec lui et que l'opéra
ne peut pas être dirigée par le pdg
d'une maison de couture
et puis de l'autre côté il ya ceux pdg
c'est pierre bergé qui explique lui que
si barenboim a agi comme cela c'est
uniquement pour une question de gros
sous
georges bigot
opéra opéra quand tu nous tiens on peut
bien dire adieu prudence aujourd'hui
folle journée des ténors
on pousse les contre ut à midi
conférence de presse de daniel barenboim
limogé il mette en cause l'honneur et la
compétence de pierre bergé il est
inadmissible qu'en tolère un public de
mensonges demi vérités c'est la mauvaise
foi mais surtout de l'incompétence calme
il s'agit d'un projet culturel d'une
importance
universal à 13h pierre bergé a d'autres
arguments
ce n'est pas une affaire politique pas
du tout c'est simplement une affaire
d'argent
et en effet dans cette corbeille
j'ai été très heureux de trouver de
monsieur daniel barenboim
en arrivant à la présidence d opéra de
paris au mois de septembre dans les
regarde une preuve de plus près
malheureusement j'ai trouvé un contrat
et ce contrat accorde à monsieur barry
bonne plus de 7 millions de francs
700 millions de centimes alors moi je
veux bien tout ce qu'on veut et je veux
bien que daniel barenboim tout à l'heure
une manière qui croient à droite dit que
président d'une maison de couture n'est
pas là pour parler d'opéra mais je suis
pas du tout là pour parler d'opéra suis
là pour gérer l'opéra
gérez bien sûr mais quand on aime on ne
compte pas et les grands professionnels
comme patrice chéreau homme de gauche
bontin solidaire de barenboim ne partage
pas cette analyse
je n'attendais pas ça de ce gouvernement
là je n'attendais pas ça d'un
gouvernement auquel je j'ai pu croire au
jeu ne devrait pas ça de gens auxquels
j'ai pu croire et je ne voulais pas ça
les gens dont je partage les idées se
trouve ça profondément choquant ce n'est
pas une question d'argent c'est une
question de responsabilité artistique
puisque c'est devenu un problème
politique
ces deux hommes politiques de choisir ce
qu'ils veulent
le président de la république doit se
trouver ce soir dans un conflit
cornélien cet opéra de la bastille
auquel il tient de temps exige un
arbitrage entre le coeur et le budget et
maintenant les affaires avec un grand a
et un petit est ce beauf en l'espace de
trois jours on est passé d'une histoire
de fraude à la bourse un grand débat
politique les affaires s'étaient échinés
et la société générale
et bien ce week-end quelques ténors de
la politique se sont emparés du problème
pour en faire une polémique idéologique
et politique alors comment on en est
venu là voici l'escaladent et quatre
derniers jours roland sicard gros titres
parfum de scandale d'une opposition qui
montent au créneau un ministre qui
accuse les affaires financières sont
devenues des affaires tout coup des
affaires qui jeudi dernier ont débouché
sur le plan politique
roger fauroux sort de l'ombre dans les
colonnes de l'express puis à la
télévision le ministre de l'industrie
interrogé sur la sphère pechiney en
évoque une autre celle de la société
générale qu'il juge encore plus grave
parce qu'elle pose un problème du rôle
des institutions comme la caisse des
dépôts c'est tout et tout le monde en
est bien d'accord il faut qu'il y ait un
débat les baillargeaux verts qui sont
sur ce problème
sap pechiney société générale roger
fauroux affirmera qu on l'a mal compris
mais l'affairé lancée
l'opposition s'en saisit dénonce
l'affairisme françois mitterrand et
michel rocard se passe à l'offensive
le président de la république dénonce
les attaques personnelles
le premier ministre dans un communiqué
renvoie l'ascenseur critiquent les
conditions dans lesquelles la droite a
mené
privatisation le ps ne tarde pas à lui
emboîter le pas l'état français n'a pas
préserver ses intérêts c'est à dire que
les sociétés ont été bradées à vil prix
qu'aujourd'hui au bénéfice de quelques
personnes qui sont obligées pouvoir y
compris le beau frère de monsieur
balladur n'est ce pas et tout ça n'a pas
été convenable les privatisations mise
en cause par le ps et c'est edouard
balladur qui montrent un son tour au
créneau
l'ancien ministre des finances réagit
mais sur un autre registre c'est une
trêve qui est proposé prenons d'abord un
thème qui me paraît l'essentiel la
moralisation de la vie financière
les opéras pour le rôle de la cob
pourquoi ne peut-on de façon si j'ose
dire bipartisane arriver à un accord
là-dessus d'attac contre attaque c'est
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans cette mêlée
politique ou boursière une mêlée qui à
deux mois des élections municipales fait
plutôt désordre
ainsi donc la droite a d'abord attaqué
sur le thème de l'affairisme du pouvoir
actuel et la gauche a répliqué sur le
thème du noyautage de certaines grandes
entreprises par la droite et ses amis
politiques en quelque sorte du copinage
ça c'est la fameuse affaire des noyaux
durs rappelez vous c'était à l'époque
des privatisations entre 86 et 88 l'un
des grands thèmes du gouvernement chirac
explications sur ces noyaux durs maryse
mano comme certaines propriétés privées
les entreprises privatisées par edouard
balladur des 86 ont eu besoin de chiens
de garde pour se protéger des intrus des
acheteurs étrangers par exemple lagarde
a été montée sur 20% du territoire
minimum 20% inattaquable qui constituent
le noyau dur de l'entreprise
ce fut le cas pour paribas havas cge
société générale et d'autres très vite
socialiste et barriste et critiquent ces
noyaux durs à leurs yeux ils ont tous le
même air de famille celui du rpr les
chirac isation il s'est agi la part de
monsieur chirac et de ses amis une
véritable entreprise de vente des
trésors nationaux du pays je veux dire
des biens nationaux au prix national de
les vendre à des amis de
tours au pouvoir les socialistes
affichent clairement leurs intentions
en dépit de la lettre de françois
mitterrand aux français qui promet ni
privatisation ni nationalisation et bien
les noyaux durs il faut en laisser
griser
ce sera chose faite chez havas en
revanche à la société générale c'est
l'échec au ps si certains sont prêts à
battre en retraite
d'autres comme jean pierre chevènement
veulent aller jusqu'au bout si on
considère que la voie du marché n'est
pas la bonne qu'elle n'est pas
transparent et c'est alors soyons francs
nationalisons autre porte de sortie
celle entrouverte par pierre bérégovoy
un projet de loi qui rendrait leur
liberté aux actionnaires alors vous le
voyez de quoi alimenter largement une
polémique mais curieusement gilles
leclair une polémique ressurgit sur des
thèmes qu'on croyait définitivement
enterrée par exemple les
nationalisations dont viennent parler
jean pierre chevènement tout à fait
alors on croyait ce débat vieux et est
quasiment enterré voilà qu'il ressort au
milieu de ce climat empoisonné par les
affaires privatisations nationalisation
le bien et le mal ou le mal et le bien
suivant son camp mais c'est vrai la
contre attaque des socialistes s'est
bien développée dans cette direction une
contre attaque qui peut certes rassurer
les militants mais qui ne se situent pas
on vient le voir dans la droite ligne de
la lettre aux français exprimée par
françois mitterrand le président on s'en
souvient qui s'était montré au cours de
la campagne électorale plutôt prudent
sur ce chapitre
et c'est vrai qu'il y encore en tout cas
un débat sur ce sujet chez les
socialistes
il n'y a pas unanimité entre les
courants d'abord entre les ambitions
entre les anciens et les modernes
il n'y a pas qu'un seul mot d'ordre
premier débat d'abord fallait-il ou non
en 86 toucher aux dispositifs balladur
ensuite second débat quelle méthode
fallait-il employer la manière forte
autre chose en fait de gilles tout
dépend des du contexte politique bien
entendu d'abord il faut le rappeler
c'est michel rocard qui s'est installée
à matignon où l'ont avoué d'ailleurs cet
après midi ne pas prendre au sérieux du
tout les pronostics de jean pierre
chevènement
d'autant que malgré les municipales et
les retrouvailles avec le parti
communiste il convient toujours pour le
premier ministre de ne pas effaroucher
les centristes alors dénoyautage si
besoin
oui mais il faudra dorénavant beaucoup
plus de cartes et vous voyez ce sont
bien les problèmes de transparence et de
règles du jeu qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'ordre
jours c'est d'ailleurs valable pour la
droite comme pour la gauche à l'heure de
l'ouverture du marché unique où la
finance
on le voit bien risque de prendre encore
plus le pas sur tout le reste
merci gilles et pour clore complètement
ce chapitre politique je vous rappelle
que l'invité de l'heure de vérité
aussitôt après le journal fait georges
marchais pour lionel jospin c'est une
semaine décisive qui commence première
vraie grande confrontation le ministre
de l'éducation avec le monde de
l'enseignement
à partir de demain il va recevoir toutes
les parties prenantes thème général la
revalorisation de la fonction
enseignante
michel rocard a lancé la machine en
débloquant des crédits maintenant les
nageuses pas va mettre tout cela en
pratique
dominique laurie demain premier dossier
la rénovation du système scolaire
c'est-à-dire le contenu des
enseignements avec le rééquilibrage des
études de lettres par rapport aux
mathématiques l'introduction de
l'anglais à l'école primaire les rythmes
scolaires il est question de rallonger
l'année scolaire ce qui va réduire
d'autant les vacances des enseignants et
diminuer la journée de travail des
écoliers journée actuellement de six
heures la plus longue d'europe 55
organisations participent à ces
négociations
parmi elles un représentant de la
fédération indépendante des lycées que
nous soyons reçus demain par les
ministères éducation à la table ronde
qu'il organise avec tous les partenaires
l'application nationale pour nous c'est
réellement une chose positive c'est la
première fois qu'on le voit mercredi
deuxième partie une négociation bien
plus délicate
uniquement avec les syndicats sur la
revalorisation de la fonction
enseignante
il s'agit des salaires et du recrutement
là les difficultés commencent le snes
réclament au minimum 1000 fond
d'augmentation pour tous les enseignants
nous considérons qu'une prépa d'anormal
dans ce pays de porter les salaires de
début de carrière à 10000 francs et les
salaires de fin de carrière à plus de 20
mille francs pour tous les enseignants
ont tous les enseignants ce qui est
impensable compte tenu des six milliards
déjà débloqués avec difficulté par le
gouvernement la fédération de
l'éducation nationale pour sa part
manifeste bien plus de souplesse
les usagers du système éducatif
les enseignants les personnels non
enseignants du système éducatif
le pays tout entier attendent que ça
réussisse
personne personne n'a intérêt à ce que
ça échoue il faut ajouter pour être
complet que lionel jospin manifeste un
sérieuse agacement après les
déclarations répétées de michel rocard
annonçant avant même la négociation le
montant de l'enveloppé budgétaire
proposée par le gouvernement
bref la négociation qui va s'ouvrir
demain dans cette salle ne sera pas sans
embûche pour lionel jospin les prix ont
augmenté de 3,1 pour cent au cours de
l'année 88 objectif pratiquement atteint
pour le gouvernement de michel rocard il
s'était fixé 3% pour l'année l'insee
viennent en effet de publier les
chiffres provisoires du dernier mois
celui de décembre en un mois une hausse
de 0,2 pour cent qui succède qui succès
de à la hausse de 0,1 pour cent en
novembre des chips des chiffres
abstraits mais qui traduisent en tout
cas que l'inflation en france est en ce
moment bien ralenti attention demain
certaines de vos agences bancaires
seront peut-être fermer en effet un mot
d'ordre de grève a été lancé par trois
syndicats dans ce secteur fo la cfdt et
la cftc 3 syndicats qui représentent en
fait les trois quarts des personnels des
banques
motif de la grève les salaires et les
craintes pour l'emploi
jean-pierre motivé après la sidérurgie
jacques chérèque va-t-il s'occuper des
banques
le ministre la reconversion s'inquiète
discrètement semble-t-il d'une
accélération possible de la baisse des
effectifs dans les banques
un risque auquel curieusement ceux qui
appellent à la grève demain ne crois pas
du tout à l'heure actuelle on peut pas
dire que l'on puisse parler de la banque
s'ils dérangent et ce qui est vrai c'est
que les emplois sont régulièrement
supprimés depuis plusieurs années
maintenant dans une moyenne de 1 à 2 %
l'an pourtant regardez voici une
nouvelle génération de guichet qui
encaisse chaque ou liquide tout cela
sans aucun employé là attention ce n'est
plus l'informatique de papa
et antoine candau qui était banquier
informaticiens voici trois mois encore
explique pourquoi toutes les activités
de conseil qui sont dispensés au guichet
des agences de quartier toutes les
activités de conseil classique sur les
crédits à la consommation les crédits à
l'habitat tout ça peut dès maintenant
dire aujourd'hui pour peu qu'on veuille
investir l'argent nécessaire et surtout
pour peu qu'on ait la volonté politique
de faire ça peut être remplacée en
quelques mois
par-dessus partisans dînatoire demain il
s'agira d'un test de mobilisation
si la grève était suivie les syndicats
envisagent d'autres d'ici ou de 10
février date d'une négociation sur les
salaires à laquelle il aimerait bien
ajouter les problèmes d'emploi citroën
pris en faute l'usiné d'aulnay sous bois
employer des travailleurs intérimaires
mais pour que ça lui coûte moins cher
elle faisait durer l'intérim beaucoup
plus longtemps qu'elle en avait le droit
l'inspection du travail a tapé du poing
sur la table fbt yanji quel reportage 50
intérimaires organisé en commando un
mois que ces jeunes ouvriers qui
travaillent chez citroën font des
démarches auprès des sociétés d'intérim
qui les emploie
pour obtenir le paiement de primes
qu'ils jugent leur revenir mais cette
fois-ci leur démarche à payer alors y'a
5493 179 2600 francs environ 70
donc on a eu à l'acompte sur le
treizième mois 1 et la prochaine fois on
aura tous on la paye du mois de février
on aura tous donc là visiblement bon on
a gagné on va donner savez moi c'est pas
normal qu on fait fort sill faire des
démarches
aujourd'hui je devrais être au boulot en
résulta suis venu s'il a loupé ma
journée
on va peut-être que l'industrie
mois normal normalement si un adulte ça
doit être mis sur nos fiches de paye
d'office était près deux ans une
nouvelle 4 5 france ô notre paye tous
les mois
le code du travail est formel les
travailleurs temporaires doivent toucher
les mêmes salaires et les mêmes primes
que les travailleurs permanents de
l'entreprise au même fosse or ces
intérimaires qui travaillent dans
l'usiné citroën d'aulnay se sont aperçus
que les primes de fin d'année et de
rentrer que perçoivent les permanents
citroën n'était pas prise en compte dans
le calcul de leur salaire
les sociétés d'intérim refuse de
répondre devant la caméra c'est la faute
de citroën distel qui ne nous a jamais
dit que c'est permanent toucher ses
primes
faux répond citroën qui renvoient la
balle d'où elle vient demander sociétés
d'intérim d'examiner l'ensemble des
dossiers concernés et
leur avons demandé de régulariser les
anomalies qui pouvaient exister
alors comment peut-on expliquer que
pendant près de deux ans des
intérimaires n'ai pas été payé
conformément à la loi
ça il faudra le demander aux sociétés
d'intérim et je dirai ce moment là parce
que pour notre part
estimant qu' il n'y aurait pas de
problème d'un autre côté bref personne
ne veut être le père de l'infraction
pour l'inspection du travail en revanche
citroën à bien sa part de responsabilité
l' agence d'intérim ne peut définir le
tarif du post si vous voulez que dans la
mesure où l'utilisateur lui donne les
éléments et la l'utilisateur terre
d'entreprises utilisatrices à gauche
responsabilité puisque c'est elle qui
connaît parfaitement le tarif du post
l'inspection du travail s'occupe
aujourd'hui d'un autre problème le
recours massif de citroën à l'intérim à
l'usiné d'aulnay sur 5500 ouvriers 330
100 intérimaires certains travaillent
depuis 22 mois
au bangladesh c'est sans doute une
erreur humaine qui est à l'origine de la
collision entre deux trains au sud de
dacca le bilan est encore provisoire
mais il est très lourd
plusieurs centaines de morts et plus de
mille blessés phobos maintenant de voir
d'autres informations de l'actualité de
ce lundi michel mompontet hier à prague
trois mille personnes ont tenté malgré
l'interdiction des autorités de
commémorer le 20e anniversaire du
suicide de jan palach ils ont tout juste
le temps de crier liberté
les unités anti-émeutes très présentes
sur les lieux ont violemment dispersé
les manifestants et 80 arrestations
plusieurs dizaines de blessés graves
yann pas l'âge est mort le 16 janvier
1969 en s'immolant par le feu
il ne supportait pas de voir son pays
vivre sans liberté c'était il ya vingt
ans c'était hier
monte melkonian le fondateur du
mouvement clandestins arméniens à salah
a été libéré aujourd'hui la centrale de
poissy
il y purgeait une peine de quatre ans
pour détention d'armes
il n'a bénéficié d'aucune mesure de
grâce il sera très vraisemblablement
expulsés de france dans les prochaines
24 heures
edith cresson et son homologue allemand
ont cet après midi presque effacé la
frontière entre les deux pays
les panneaux classiques de douane ont en
effet cédé la place aux panneaux
européen fond bleu étoilé vaut peut-être
mieux entre les deux pays
une bande blanche que représente le fait
d'avoir 20 ans en 1989 et bien c'est le
thème de toute une série d' enquête dans
nos journaux cette semaine en
collaboration avec le journal l'étudiant
nous ont parlé ainsi tout au long de la
semaine des jeunes de tous les milieux
ce soir portrait d'un ouvrier de 20 ans
il parle de ses choix de ses goûts mais
aussi de ses rêves
monique atlan stéphane cref à 20 ans il
travaille à la papeterie de la scène il
a d'abord été manutentionnaires depuis
un mois ils réceptionnent vieux papier
il vient d'être augmentée pour lui en 89
la priorité c'est son emploi
mon but pour l'instant pour aller moi le
mois qui vient c'est au niveau du boulot
réussir ce que je peux ce que je dois
faire et de réussir
après quand on verra pour l'instant
stéphane habite toujours chez ses
parents
la famille compte beaucoup pour lui mais
s'il reste d'amour c'est toujours avec
l'ombre portée du sida le site donne
aussi d'un mois ça me tracasse ce truc
là 23 15 pourquoi moi ça fait peur ça
fait peur ça fait peur
j'y pense maintenant mais quand j'y vais
j'y pense pas moins l'amour l'amour très
belles choses à deux choses l'amour mais
ça je préfère pas en parler parce que ça
fait trois semaines que je suis en
indifférent à la politique
touché par les problèmes de solidarité
le mot révolution ne le concerne pas
alors ça m'inspire pas du tout alors là
pas du tout 1789 dont on entend parler
depuis quelques mois mais ça va ça me
branche pas du tout la politique la
politique pour se plaint de blabla pour
pallier à grand chose que ce soient de
gauche ou tour édition de vous parler
c'est une mauvaise opinion des syndicats
et puis une bonne de plus en plus des
mauvaises opinions par le même
d'ailleurs
et tout ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques semaines voir que 150 personnes
200 personnes puissent bloquer les
milliers de personnes à paris c'est
ridicule l'indiqué vous même nom moi ce
qui me choque c'est
c'est de voir des fondations style
restos du coeur on sait bien d'accord
mais je trouve qu'en qu'en 1989 comme ça
sauve en l'an 2000 c'est votre jeu
réaliste et ça devrait pas exister
à l'image de sa génération stéphane a
des rêves sage de réussite et de bonheur
tranquille juste teinté d'un geste d'
aventure quoi je rêve moi
je sais pas je crois c'est peut-être le
tour du monde
c'est irréaliste mais on sait jamais
pourquoi la littérature policière avait
son tandem c'était bien sûr boileau et
narcejac eh bien il faut dire cela au
passé maintenant car pierre boileau est
mort à l'âge de 82 ans
ensemble nous à l'honneur ce jacques ont
publié quarante trois romans il était
traduit dans 20 langues
s'il dit marion boileau et narcejac les
maîtres du suspense on ne pouvait pas
imaginer l'un sans l'autre
boileau c'était lui et que fera narcejac
sans son complice car boileau c'était le
cerveau du célèbre tandem s'est lui dit
trouver les idées les intrigues
c'est extravagant et du lissieu
cauchemar qui nous faisait oublier nos
salles petit cauchemar quotidien nous
narcejac lui écrivait faut dire que pour
chacun des blocs à l'état une manière
différente
des fois c'est un milieu social une
profession encore geographic
je me rappelle medrano nous sommes allé
une fois medrano il y avait une autre
action formidable de faire une
performance il ya quelque chose à faire
je viens pas nous ce dont nous nous
souvenons c'est surtout des deux romans
qui sont devenus des chefs-d'oeuvre au
cinéma les diaboliques de clouzot et
sueurs froides de hitchcock
les deux complices venait de publier
contrat leur dernier roman aux éditions
denoël et leurs oeuvres complètes dans
la collection bouquins chez robert
laffont
l'année des animaux pour le cinéma en 88
et 89 commence sous les mêmes auspices
en tout cas si l'on en croit la tendance
du festival du film fantastique
d'avoriaz festival qui a lieu cette
semaine
il y a eu un lourd si vous le savez le
lapin rogers habite et bien au festival
d'avoriaz d'il ya toutes sortes
d'animaux parfois plus inquiétant et là
on n'hésite pas à aborder les vraies
questions par exemple
l'homme est il si différent de l'animal
au fond
jean jacques dufour dans les auteurs et
les neiges la petite bête immonde
décidément les animaux sont à la mode
puissante chambre de trois films
fantastiques présentés cette année
avoriaz terrienne de maeyer fini c'est
un serpent acteurs de jérôme boivin avec
un chien et incident de parcours de
romero rompant avec un instant parcours
est un film formidable haletant qui
posent au delà de l'histoire l'étrange
relation unissant un homme et un singe
la question du combat que nous devons
mener pour contrôler nos instincts
bestiaux
on vous les trouvez vous n'avez pas de
sens je vais à côté je vous regarde
bon ça va épatant et battant nantes
votive a beau film épatant bien
scénarisé bien tourner bien foutu dans
cette ambiance à rien peu affolée baxter
premier film du français jean boivin met
en scène un bull terrier qui pensent
lutins film sur les animaux c'est un
film sur les hommes le film montre que
les hommes peuvent être beaucoup plus
féroce et beaucoup plus méchant que
certains animaux
peu d'états risée tous ces animaux
fantastiques porte légèrement au bras jo
comédiens présents ainsi que les acteurs
son cabot mais je crois que les animaux
nous battre quoi ya pas de preuve
reste à espérer que les membres du jury
ne seront pas chien avec ces films là au
moment des récompenses
demain il ya un tiercé c'est à vincennes
voici les pronostics de pierrette brès
le 16 le dise le 14 le 13 le 15 le 9 le
10 sept
et puis le 11 voilà dans un instant la
météo de laurent cabrol dans le
brouillard enfin c'est la météo qui dans
le brouillard s'est pas cabrol dernier
journal ce sera henri sannier vaut aux
environs de minuit
et puis télématin demain premier journal
de la rédaction 7h dans télématin
présentée par marc hautement et
catherine ceylac à demain soir 20h